See? We just make each other better.
Hello.
You are all out of orange juice.
I understand.
I have to go out for orange juice.
Yes, I understand.
Mitchell, I have to go out for orange juice.
I have a problem with Russians.
Being married to a Pritchett is great.
So great.
The best.
But they can be a tad judgmental.
Almost punitive.
They are monsters.
That's why the three of us formed a secret
alliance to help each other cover up our-
our little mistakes.
Like back in December when I hastily
purchased an expensive prop for an open
house. Thanks so much for hiding it.
Claire would kill me.
And it's only till Monday when I can return
it.
Don't worry.
Hide! Hide!
Hi. Oh.
Welcome home.
You're so early, right?
Not really.
There is that smile that I love.
Why don't you take me to lunch?
Okay. What happened here anyway?
You get into Joe's scented markers again?
So now I have scary Russian squatters who
won't leave. We'll have a small window when
Mitchell goes to the gym. He usually
stretches, takes a lap around the locker
room, and then gets a smoothie.
You to deal with the Russians, and I'll keep
Mitch distracted. Anything else?
Yes.
Our gate is broken, and Stella keeps getting
out in the street. I bought her a shock
collar.
We thought about getting one when Luke was
younger. Claire ended up just shaking a can
of pennies at him.
It spooked her and she's hiding.
We need to find her before Jay doesn't see
the collar. He has warned me many times not
to get one because they are cruel.
All right, we'll deal with the Russians first
and come find Stella before the big vote.
We do not have much time.
We need to go.
I actually ordered a sandwich.
What are you doing here?
Oh, I just came through the unsecured back
door. Hello again.
Hi.
We're still interested in your house.
We just might be leaning towards this one.
Oh, I'm very surprised.
People that like cooking so much.
Are you guys going to be happy with this
tiny little pantry that leads to a gigantic
pantry?
Are you ready to see the interactive nursery?
Oh, the baby just kicked.
Hey, are you all about to be my new neighbor?
Hope you like to party.
My name's Fred. They call me peeper because,
well, that doesn't matter.
Oh, yeah. Look at the chocolate chip
cookies. Kids, get in here.
Get yourselves some supper.
These are my blessings.
Do I like ethnic women?
Guilty. Do you like farm-fresh eggs?
I sold my very first house and destroyed my
swooper. Of course, the
only way you can destroy a real swooper is to
stab its reflection during the harvest moon.
All right. We shouldn't be panicking, right?
No, of course not. There's got to be a
million ways out of here.
There's a security camera.
Oh.
Oh, no, no, no, it's old and broke.
Help! Help!
We're stuck in here!
Gloria, that didn't work five minutes ago and
it didn't work ten minutes ago.
Why can't they hear me?
This vent has to go somewhere.
Gloria Maria Ramirez Delgado Pritchett, you
are a genius.
I know. Give me a boost.
No, it should be me. You're right.
Gloria, give cam a boost.
No, I mean,
I should give you a boost.
The process works.
Why don't we use that trunk?
See, we just make each other better.
Chair. Chair, who needs Pritchetts?
I'll steady it. Thank you again.
Yeah. Okay.
Okay, great.
You're great.
Oh.
Great. Oh, God.
All right.
Let's Die-Hard this puppy.
Oh, that's my shoulder.
All right. Okay, in we go.
All right. Now, Phil, every couple feet
knock so we know where you are.
Got it.
Okay, guys, I think I see an opening.
We're saved.
Yipee-Ki-Yay Mother-- Oh dear God.
Phil. Phil. Phil.
Good news guys, I see two people.
Maybe I can get it. Oh, it's you.
I'm gonna be the belle of the ball in this
dress. Stealing this award has given me the
confidence to crush everyone in my path.
Permiso.
I never even saw Gloria go into the dressing
room. But there she was, like a superhero,
able to destroy confidence in a single pose.
I'm glad I didn't go with the first dress.
They'll take one look at this one and make
me principal.
Oh, come on!
You know what? Maybe you should try the dress
on that lady's wearing.
Oh my God, that was brilliant and humbling.
You know, I pride myself on solving people
problems. You know what?
You still have the swooper. Maybe I could-
No, thanks.
She just can't accept help, but I can.
I'm thinking about rocking this for my date
with Brenda. Ignore the buttons.
Can you tell this is a woman's coat?
Yes.
There's nothing I can do.
I can't go for that.
No can do.
Cameron here bought an eggshell drier.
Not white, not oatmeal, not Swiss coffee.
Not baby powder. Not bone.
Eggshell. Look, Rob, is it?
That's interesting.
Here's how this is going down.
We don't leave without that eggshell drier.
Not swan feather, not Chester pig white.
I think we've
Covered the colors.
I sell houses to people every day who ask me
where they should buy their dryer.
I don't think you want me giving them any
static.
I may have one in the back, but it takes two
guys to load the truck.
And it's just me today.
Is it?
It was right about then that a question
started nagging at me.
Is Phil sexy?
There she is. Stella!
Hi. Thank God you found my dog.
Thank you.
This is my dog. Her name's Pinkie.
No it's not. Her name is Stella.
It says right here on the tag.
Look.
Uh. Excuse me.
Hi, sweetie. What's your name?
Blanche. Shut up.
Mitchell would die.
Listen, we don't know you.
You seem like a very sweet little girl.
And right now, we're forced to.
I can't believe I'm saying this to you.
Rely on the kindness of strangers.
I'll sell it to you for $200.
That's it.
Give me my dog.
Ahhh! Oh, really? The little girl thinks
because she can scream.
She can get away with everything?
I can scream too.
Ah!
Ah! Ah! Ahhhh!
What the hell sound is that?
Who knows how long this has been going on,
okay? They've been in cahoots, covering up
each other's mistakes before we've even had
a chance to shame them.
Since this little alliance made a decision to
go behind our backs. Maybe we should make a
decision without them.
Oh. Like where we're going on vacation?
No.
No, no, I like it, I like it.
Let's do this. Let's go vote.
Yep.
Yep. You got it.
Okay, we've reached a decision.
Drum roll please. Close enough.
The family is going to...
Italy!
Awwww, no.
The cutest part is that they think it was
their idea.
What are you making?
I'm making an Italian dish that Jay's mother
used to make.
Breakfast
lasagna. Great call, Honey.
Oh. Hey, sweetie.
Your breakfast is on the table.
What's this?
Oh. I've named him.
It's Giovanni.
I'm still thinking about that movie last
night.
You picked a good one.
Only the Italians could make something that
romantic.
Flapjacks for me amore.
Oh, grazie.